>> This item,
from the Law Library's Rare Book Vault.
>> is a petition for writ of process
in Sangamon County Circuit, Court, Illinois
in the case of George M. Stockton versus James Tolley.
>> It was handwritten by a young lawyer named Abraham Lincolnin 1839.
Abraham Lincoln signed this document “Stuart & Lincoln.”
>> “Stuart” is a reference to Abraham Lincoln’s first law partner
and Mary Todd Lincoln’s cousin, John Todd Stuart.
>> John Todd Stuart was born near Lexington, KY, graduated from Centre College and was admitted to the Illinois Bar in 1828.
Stuart met Abraham Lincoln during the Black Hawk War,in which both served as members of the militia.
>> Stuart had a significant influence on the course of Lincoln’s life by encouraging him to study law, and lending him books to prepare for the bar.
The two became law partners from 1837 to 1841.
>> John Todd Stuart was a politician in his own right, having served in the Illinois House of Representatives
and the U.S. House of Representatives as a Whig and, later, as a Democrat during the Lincoln administration.
>> Stuart found occasion to disagree with Lincoln politically, backing John Bell in the 1860 presidential election
, and opposing some of Lincoln’s policies, including emancipation.
>> Nevertheless, Stuart remained friends with Lincoln, and was a frequent visitor to the White House.
>> While Stuart and Lincoln’s office was in Springfield, in the spring and fall, Lincoln had to ride circuit,
which meant traveling hundreds of miles for court days held in rural Central Illinois county seats.
>> Like most lawyers of his day, Lincoln was a jack of all trades, arguing everything from contract and probate disputes, to a small number of criminal cases.
>> Lincoln even made an appearance before the United States Supreme Court in Lewis v. Lewis, a case that turned on a statute of limitations,
>> but the bulk of his practice involved debt collection. Of the five-thousand known cases that involved Lincoln in some capacity, 2,600 were some form of debtor-creditor litigation.
>> Lincoln had two partners after his partnership with Stuart was dissolved in 1841.
>> It has been said that before Lincoln departed Springfield for Washington in 1861, he pointed at the sign on his office and remarked to William Herndon, his last law partner, to "Let it hang there undisturbed.
>> Give our clients to understand that the election of a President makes no change in the firm of Lincoln and Herndon. If I live, I'm coming back sometime, and then we'll go right on practicing law as if nothing had ever happened."